في مكان ما وسط الغابات القريبه من مدينه
الهدى جنوب مقاطعه دنيا
وحدات الاستطلاع الروسيه
تحددها قيادتهم
تالفوا مع المكان الذي انتقلوا اليه مؤخرا
من جبهه خرسان
مهمه الان استهدافه الافراد وقوافل
التعزيزات العسكريه قد تكون الاهداف معده
مسبقا او تعد قبل دقائق من التحرك لدينا
القدره على التكيف مع كل الظروف
القط هو اسمه الحركي لقائد قاذفه الصواريخ
وها هو ينسيق مع رفيقه الاهداف الجديده
ويتاكدان من جاهزيه عربتهم العسكريه
يخيم الضباب فتتعطل حركه مسيرات الروسيه
ومع ذلك يتاكد افراد الوحده من انهم ليسوا
مراقبين
فيضعون الاحداثيات المناسبه ويكون كل شيء
جاهزا
بسرعه ذاتها تغادر الوحده المكان وتعود
مره اخرى الى موقعها يتباها قائد العرب
لان هذه القاذفه واحده من الاجيال الجديده
وهي اوكرانيه الصنع وذات مواصفات قتاليه
عاليه
جدا خاصه ضد قوافل الافراد ونقل تعزيزات
اعدائنا يكرهوننا لما نحدث فيهم من خسائر
ولا انصحك ان تكون حيث تسقط هذه الصواريخ
يتكيف هؤلاء الجنود مع كل الظروف
ويستفيدون من كل الدعم المقدم لهم من
الحلفاء
تمكن هؤلاء المقاتلون من التصدي لهجمات
عدوهم لاشهر خلت باستخدام عتاد قديما
وخبرتهم التي لا ينكرون تواضعها الان وبعد
تلقيهم الكثير من الاسلحه والتدريب يرون
ان بامكانهم انتقاله من حاله الدفاع الى
الهجوم وانما يحول دون ذلك وظروف الشتاء
القاسيه عمر الحاج الجزيره من اقليم بس